a new grindelwald an old call back and a
mysterious absence what do all these
things add up to and do we ever find out
the secrets of dumbledore here are the
best and worst things about fantastic
beasts three
fans have waited for the wizarding world
franchise to officially address
dumbledore's sexuality ever since writer
jk rowling stated that the headmaster
had a love affair with grindelwald in
his youth but with rowling never
offering any canonical confirmation and
two dumbledore grindelwald centric
fantastic beasts prequels having come
and gone fans had begun to think the day
would never come yet at the beginning of
secrets of dumbledore the love affair
between grindelwald and dumbledore is
explicitly confirmed during a dinner
chat with the burgeoning dictator
dumbledore admits that he had previously
gone along with grindelwald because he
was in love with him though the lines
confirming a romantic connection only
amassed about six seconds and were cut
from certain international markets that
might be enough for fans it was you who
said we could reshape the world
but it was our birthright
fans related to see muggle jacob
brandishing a seemingly functional ones
in the film's trailers alas deceptive
editing has struck once again as the
film elaborates that jacob's weapon is
made of snake wood and doesn't even have
a core on one hand it makes far more
sense that jacob isn't a no match born
wizard yet to tap into his powers
however if he had just a teensy bit of
lingering magic from an ancestor it
would explain why he so easily recalled
magical events after getting obliviated
neither harry potter nor fantastic
beasts have explored this possibility
but it makes sense that there are
varying levels of powers in wizards we
already know that some wizards struggle
with spell work while others saw so
who's to say the wrong people with a
dollop of latent magic that can be used
in a pinch but isn't powerful enough to
board the hogwarts express technically
the movies could still explore this down
the line since jacob's wand is a dead to
begin with but overall the bait and
switch is pretty lame
the fantastic beast films gave fans an
adult glimpse at the wizarding world
that offers a different perspective than
what audiences got from the original
movies nevertheless it sure is nice to
come home well the first two fantastic
beasts movies featured hogwarts
minimally secrets of dumbledore
recaptures the unbridled magic from the
harry potter films the adult fandom can
now relive their youth with a nostalgic
homage that doesn't take away from the
plot the movie treats fans to gorgeous
aerial shots of hogwarts filled with
nods to the original series these
moments will transport fans directly
back to their childhood providing
valuable reminders of why this battle is
so important while the fantastic beast
films of adults waging this war against
tyranny rather than children they are
fighting for the future that will give
those children their moment in the sun
there's a certain generational beauty to
that hogwarts will never stop being home
for fans and these reminders of what's
at stake puts the overall battle into
grand perspective
if we're to defeat him you'll have to
trust me
the romanticization of snape and
dumbledore was bad enough in the harry
potter series when harry named his son
albus severus after the bravest men he
ever knew fans know that although both
snape and dumbledore had their moments
stape only turned away from voldemort's
murderous mission after the death of
lily a woman he essentially stalked for
years prior to his redemption snape was
perfectly content to let lily's son and
husband die at the hands of voldemort so
his rebellion against voldemort wasn't
exactly noble he even went on to bully
his supposed love son for seven years
yet despite snape's behavior toward lily
and his selfish obsessive love for her
fans still romanticize the word always
the line references a time when snape
uses his patronus in front of dumbledore
when dumbledore sees that's name's
patronus is still lily's stag he asks
after all this time
[Music]
always
cut to the secrets of dumbledore when
aberforth meets his son credence who
asks did you ever think of me aberforth
says always not only is it an
unnecessary nod to snape but it's also
more proof that aberforth knew about his
son and did little to nothing to find
him
dumbledore and grindelwald are two of
the most compelling mysterious and
utterly confounding characters in the
wizarding world franchise with their
epic plot line that has played out in
these three films it's easy to sometimes
forget that the series is called
fantastic beasts duke scamander and his
little critters often feel like an
afterthought the secrets of dumbledore
brings the creatures back to the
forefront of the story making their
appearances integral to the rapidly
darkening overall storyline harry potter
has always been heavy on mythology and
the chilean's mythos and the secrets of
dumbledore is directly tied to the
film's upcoming election in the new
movie these creatures aid in choosing
the leader of the magical world bowing
to someone worthy of the title while
being integral to the story the
chilean's birth is also a stunning
impactful moment for the franchise as a
whole given that dumbledore was harry's
hero and mentor in the original series
which takes place from the young
wizard's point of view it's only natural
that he would glamorize the headmaster's
behavior however fantastic beasts is an
adult series and it's time to hold
dumbledore accountable for his actions
for starters why is it that after it's
been established many times that
dumbledore should avoid power the
chilean kneels down before him the
chilean bowing to dumbledore and does
all those lessons and feels like pure
fan service given that the movie's title
is secrets of dumbledore it would be
nice if the film honed in on the
mysteries and mistakes of dumbledore
rather than painting him in a flawless
light
both the harry potter and fantastic
beasts movies are inherently political
in nature given that they feature
dictators rising to power yet since the
original series took place at a school
filled with youngsters it prevented fans
from diving too deep into the politics
of it all now with adult characters
hailing from various countries secrets
of dumbledore offers the most in-depth
look yet at wizarding politics and how
an election is held the film explores
ancient rituals for determining new
leaders with such elements as the
introduction of the chileans the movie
also rectifies the second film's mistake
of glamorizing grindelwald with new
quotes that blatantly say in effect
dictators are bad all in all the movie
manages to add a touch of magic to the
politics of the series while honing in
on how a megalomaniac like grindelwald
could manipulate voters and hold an
election hostage luckily newton's merry
band of misfits make grindelwald's reign
as an official leader short-lived this
would have been only the beginning of
grindelwald's reign of terror if by tea
time all of us are still alive
we should consider our efforts a success
the recast from johnny depp to mass
mickelson is striking but it's not just
a change in actor that is glaringly
obvious grindelwald's entire aesthetic
from hair all the way down to his
personality is completely reimagined in
the new film there doesn't even seem to
be any effort to make them feel the same
which will make it difficult to re-watch
the fantastic beasts movies together
someday nevertheless it might be smart
michelson and deb are two extremely
different actors and it seems foolhardy
to ask the former to mimic the latter so
it's refreshing to see mickelson play
the character with more of a simmering
twisted approach than the overt maniacal
way depp approached it the plotline
calls for a charming duplicitous quality
to the dictator for his rise to power to
be believable after all if secrets had
offered a tangible reason for
grindelwald's new appearance however it
would have made the films flow so much
better
magical creatures were the name of the
game in 2016's fantastic beasts and
where to find them the crimes of
grindelwald was a messy mishmash of a
sequel now secrets of dumbledore takes
fans back to what they love most about
the wizarding world franchise the magic
most of the harry potter movies had at
least one epic one wielding duel
particularly in the later installments
secrets does a terrific job escalating
tension as it gets to the big election
and the final battle in its aftermath
the first significant clash between
dumbledore and grindelwald that we've
ever seen on screen witnessing
grindelwald's murder of the chilean
serves as a reminder that he is a
dangerous ruthless man and things
quickly escalate from there not only
does the moment show grindelwald's
murderous impulsivity but it also offers
a glimpse of what grindelwald is truly
capable of when he declares war on the
muggle world grindelwald and
dumbledore's battle results in a spell
vortex for grindelwald and dumbledore
there's an added level of heartbreak
when the pair audibly hear each other's
heartbeats the result is far and away
the most climactic ending to any of the
fantastic beasts films it also carries
with it an appropriate level of heart
magic incredible special effects and a
tease for what's to come
if you check the website does the dog
die before tuning into any movie
involving an animal you're not alone it
can be painful and even triggering to
watch creatures get brutally murdered
even pretend ones with secrets of
dumbledore fans are forced to bear
witness to not one but two savage death
scenes for the angelic deer-like
chileans after newt assists and the
wondrous birth of the chilean twins a
group of grindelwald's minions show up
firing killing curses at them one hits
the mama chillin and we watch her slowly
die as she sees her baby carted off by
the enemy before newt notices her second
baby the heartbeat of the harry potter
franchise has always been a threefold of
love loss and the will to keep fighting
while the ending of the crimes of
grindelwald seemed like it could be a
final nail in the coffin of queenie and
jacob's sweet romance the secrets of
dumbledore reminds fans that almost no
one is beyond saving if they choose to
be better despite queenie's lapse in
judgment when she witnesses
grindelwald's cruelty first hand she can
no longer abide helping him queenies
turn back to the right side of the war
the love she shares with jacob and their
wedding at the end of the film are
exactly what the characters and fans
need to keep fighting for a future of
love and tolerance
corbin tina goldstein has been a staple
of the fantastic beast films from the
very beginning while she's underutilized
in crimes of grindelwald her absence is
even more noticeable in secrets of
dumbledore a handful of scenes she
appears in consist of her simply
reacting to the film's events without
much substance given that she was
promoted to the head of the usara office
off-screen her absence is even more
perplexing it's reasonable to assume
that she would help out with some of the
political uprisings shown throughout the
movie the movie doesn't even have a
throwaway line that tina is on a top
secret assignment either she's just
absent while some fans have guessed that
tina's absence is due to actress
catherine waterstone's unequivocal
criticism of j.k rowling's controversial
comments nothing has been confirmed by
warner brothers as of the making of this
video whether that's the cause or not
it's the movie's job to have tina's
absence make sense plot-wise and in that
respect it really falls short
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]